they were brothers who were Incredibly
Close
eight-year-old Finley Butler and little
Samuel who was six
the boys had been playing with their
older cousin eleven-year-old Thomas
Stewart when they fell into this frozen
lake in solihull on Sunday
all three lost their lives along with
another boy ten-year-old Jack Johnson
his dad and a passerby had rushed into
the water to try to save him but
couldn't a member of Jack's family told
me that they don't ever want to see
another family go through this they said
the children simply didn't see the harm
and danger in playing on the ice it was
simply fun to them they want people to
warn their children not to take risks on
Open Water
it was hoped that Samuel might pull
through he fought for his life for three
days it was a fight he couldn't win
his parents said as a family we are
devastated at the loss of our beautiful
boys Tom Finn and Sam in such tragic
circumstances we would like to thank the
emergency services for all they did in
rescuing the boys and to the community
for their support it has been
overwhelming
earlier paramedics who tried to revive
the boys came to stop reflect and pay
tribute I think it's difficult really to
to have a lot of three children already
and there was always hope during the
week that um perhaps there was an
opportunity that the the last little lab
would have survived unfortunately that's
not the case the community is now
fundraising to pay for the funerals of
the four boys who will always be missed
Lisa Dowd Sky News solihull